she's a media producer actress talk show
host and philanthropist she's best known
for her talk show she is worth three
billion dollars she's Oprah and here her
top ten rules for success the way
through the challenge is to get still
and ask yourself what is the next right
move not think about oh I got all of
this stuff what is the next right move
and then from that space make the next
right move and the next right move and
not to be overwhelmed by it because you
know your life is bigger than that one
moment you know you're not defined by
what somebody says is a failure for you
because failure is just there to point
you in a different direction nothing
about my life is lucky nothing
a lot of grace a lot of blessings a lot
of divine order but I don't believe in
luck for me luck is preparation meeting
the moment of opportunity there is no
luck without you being prepared to
handle that moment of opportunity and so
what I would say for myself is is that
because of my hand in a hand and a force
greater than my own I have been prepared
in ways that I didn't even know I was
being prepared for and the truth is for
me and for every person every single
thing that has ever happened in your
life is preparing you for the moment
that is to come you don't have to hold
yourself hostage to who you used to be
or anything you ever used to do coz who
has lived and hasn't made mistakes when
I think about my 20s and what a foolish
girl I was and how I would give over my
power to men who really didn't mean me
well but now I hold no grudges against
them either because I realized I'm the
one who gave over the power because I
didn't know any better and now that I
know better I know I don't have to do
that again it's one of the most powerful
lessons any of us can ever know I say to
the my girls all of the time that your
real work is to figure out where your
power base is and to work on the
alignment of your personality your gifts
that you have to give with the real
reason why you're here that's that's the
number one thing you have to do is to
work on yourself and to fill your self
up and keep your cup full keep yourself
full now I used to be afraid of that I
used to be afraid particularly from
people who say ello she said she said
she's so cool herself and now I embrace
it
I considered a compliment that I am full
of myself because you only when you're
full I'm full I'm overflowing my cup
runneth over I have so much I have so
much to offer and so much to give and I
am not afraid of honoring myself you
know it's miraculous when you think
about it and I would say to my team well
doesn't matter cuz every season somebody
else was coming out one talk show to
talk shows three structures there have
been over a hundred talk shows since we
started but every time I would feel like
alright got to step up our game got to
step up our game the way you step up
your game is not to worry about the
other guy in any situation cuz you can't
control the other guy you cannot control
the other guy you only have control over
yourself so it's like running a race the
energy that it takes to look back and
see where the other guys are takes
energy away from you and if they're too
close
it scares you so that's what I would say
to my team all the time don't waste your
time in the race looking back to see
where the other guy is or what the other
guy is doing it's not about the other
guy it's about what can you do you just
need to run that race as hard as you can
you need to give everything you've got
all the time for yourself my grandmother
was a maid that's all she ever knew the
only real expectation she held for me
was that I would one day become a maid
and in her words have some good white
folks meaning people who would not speak
negatively about me who would allow me
to take food home who would be good to
me
would treat me with some level of
dignity and respect that was my
grandmother's dream for me but I had
another dream for myself another more
than a dream I had a belief for myself
and I remember watching her hang out
clothes on a line one day and say to me
you have to watch me oppa Gayle cuz one
day you'll have to do this for yourself
and knowing inside myself that that was
not going to be my life don't know how I
knew it
other than that thing that we all have
intuition or an instinct that said no
this will not be my life but because I
sensed that and was connected to that
and I remember was a very still moment
it was quiet and I was still and I was
watching her I could see her right now
with the clothes pins in her mouth and
putting them on the line and seeing the
breath because it was cold the moisture
coming from her lips and I knew that
that would not be my life
I knew that I will not be hanging
clothes on a line in a backyard in
Mississippi so I was either four or five
years old and that belief that that
would not be my life is what I held onto
for the longest of times I just no
matter what believed that there was
something bigger greater more for me I
always understood that there really was
no difference between me and the
audience at times I might have had
better shoes but at the core the core of
what really matters that we are the same
you know I know that because all of us
are seeking the same thing you're here
at this fabulous school and we'll go out
into the world and each pursue based
upon what you believe your talents are
what your skills are maybe your gifts
are but you're seeking the same thing
everybody wants to fulfill the highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being that's what you're looking for the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being and because I understand
that I understand that if you're working
in a bakery and that's where you want to
be and that may be that may be what
you've always wanted to do is to bake
pies for people or bake cakes for people
or to offer your gift then then that's
that's for you and there's no difference
between you and me except that's how
that's your platform that's your show
every day so my understanding of that
has allowed me to Neverland to reach
everyone and there's no way that you
and because that's that's what I truly
feel a lot of people don't know their
purpose and if you don't know your
purpose your immediate goal is to figure
that out because otherwise you just
wandering around here so the moment you
can figure out what it is you're
supposed to be doing
the sooner you are able to get about the
business of doing that my life is fueled
by my being and the being fuels to doing
so I come from a centered place I come
from a focused place I come from
compassion it's just my nature I come
from a willingness to understand and to
be understood and I come from wanting to
to to connect I mean the secret of that
show for 25 years is that people could
see themselves in me all over the world
they could see themselves in me and even
as I became more and more financially
successful which was a big surprise to
me I was like oh wow this is so exciting
I mean you got more than that 30,000
more than 30,000 by the time I was 30 so
so my but what what I realized is
through the whole process because I'm
grounded in my own self that although I
could have more shoes my feet stayed on
the ground although I was wearing better
shoes he's kind of cute today too so I
could keep my feet on the ground even
though I could get more shoes and I
could understand I could understand that
it really was because I was grounded
I've done the was doing and continue to
this day to do the consciousness work I
work at staying awake dear beautiful
brown skin girl
and I use the word beautiful because I
know that's never a word you would call
yourself I look into your eyes and I see
the light and hope of myself in this
photo you're just about to turn 20
posing outside the television station
where you were recently hired as a
reporter you look calm you look happy
but I know how scared you are if I could
say anything to you
it would be relax it's going to be okay
girl thank you guys so much for watching
I made this video because Valerie Brown
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below I'll
see what I can do I'd also love to know
which of Oprah's top 10 rules you
connected with the most leave it in the
comments and we're going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching it seems to believe and I'll
see you soon